bien chers collègues
rebonjour pour cette deuxième édition du
jour de notre commission d'enquête
visant à établir les raisons de la perte
de souveraineté d'indépendance
énergétique de la France nous recevons
cet après-midi madame Delphine bateau
ancienne ministre de l'Écologie du
Développement durable et de l'énergie de
2012 à 2013 et actuellement député je
vous remercie madame la ministre d'avoir
anticipé en quelque sorte notre
invitation puisque vous aviez dès
l'origine fait savoir que vous
souhaitiez être auditionné vous avez été
ministre de l'Écologie du Développement
durable et de l'énergie sous le
gouvernement héros de 2011 à 2013
20 gouvernement héros de 2011 à 2013 et
vous même de
problème de calendrier électoral
aujourd'hui
vous avez donc directement succédé à
l'audition précédente que nous recevions
Eric Besson tout à l'heure
vous disposiez en matière d'énergie d'à
peu près les mêmes compétences que
celles qui furent ensuite d'évoluent à
Madame Ségolène Royal que nous avons
auditionné en début de semaine
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions vous
avez connu les derniers soubresauts de
la gestion du dossier relatif au gaz de
schiste je retiendrai dans mon propos
introductif un événement qui a marqué
cette période l'organisation du débat
national sur la transition énergétique
qui s'est terminée
il avait été organisé un peu sur le
modèle du Grenelle de l'environnement
avec 5 collèges ou du débat national sur
les énergies
organisées en son temps par Nicole
Fontaine en 2003 il devait répondre à
quatre questions comment aller vers
l'efficacité énergétique et la sobriété
quelle trajectoire pour atteindre le mix
énergétique en 2025 quel choix en
matière d'énergie renouvelable quel coût
et quel financement sur la transition
énergétique une synthèse des travaux a
été présentée par le Conseil national du
débat sans doute pourrez-vous nous
donner quelques explications sur le
déroulement de ces travaux nous avons
avant vous auditionné entre autres
Madame lovergeon et Monsieur Colombani
qui devait s'y aller au sein du comité
des 5 saches que vous souhaitiez
constituer pour guider les débats mais
qui par l'opposition de certains acteurs
n'avaient pas pu y participer
vous pourrez corriger c'est les propos
qui nous ont rapportés après la
présentation de ces quelques éléments de
contexte il me revient simplement de
vous demander de bien vouloir prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité et rien que la vérité
merci et je vous laisse donc la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur chers collègues je vous
remercie de votre invitation à
m'exprimer devant votre commission
d'enquête et avant de répondre à toutes
vos questions je voudrais avoir un
propos liminaire toutes celles et ceux
qui viennent répondre à vos questions et
claires tel ou telle période de
l'histoire récente assurant qu'ils ont
fait au mieux dans la situation on
pourrait en déduire qu'il existe une
sorte de mystère aux origines de la
situation énergétique actuelle de la
France ou encore se réfugier dans la
thèse que cette situation s'explique par
un retournement soudain de la
conjoncture que personne ne pouvait
prévoir il n'en est rien la situation
énergétique actuelle de la France était
prévisible à la question qui aurait pu
prédire je répondrai tout le monde ce
sera le premier point de mon propos le
choc énergétique actuel était prévisible
évidemment pas dans les détails de ces
circonstances précises mais il n'y a pas
dans les grandes données qui le
sous-tendent auxquelles les
gouvernements pouvaient s'attendre et
qui pouvaient être anticipées d'abord la
hausse du prix des énergies fossiles et
ses conséquences l'ensemble des risques
associés au fait que la première énergie
consommée en France est à 63% de
l'énergie fossile importée et de
notoriété publique la France est à la
merci de la hausse des prix du baril et
des dépendances géopolitiques induits
pour son approvisionnement qui engage
son autonomie stratégique sur la scène
internationale la hausse des prix des
énergies fossiles n'est pas
conjoncturelle elle a d'ailleurs
commencé pour le pétrole comme pour le
gaz avant la guerre en Ukraine dans le
contexte de la reprise de la demande
après la première phase de la pandémie
qui avait mis à l'arrêt économie
mondiale de façon assez comparable à la
hausse qui avait suivi la crise de 2008
loin de provoquer un changement de
modèle ou la construction d'un monde
d'après les lendemains de la pandémie
ont été marqués par l'effet rebond et la
course à la reprise éc et autant
d'augmentations des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre avec un nouveau record à
défaut que l'état d'urgence climatique
est convaincu de longues dates notre
pays d'organiser une sortie rapide de la
dépendance aux énergies fossiles forcée
de constater que les enjeux de
résilience de sécurité d'indépendance
n'ont pas davantage guidé les choix
publics or les sources
d'approvisionnement de la France en
hydrocarbures bien que diversifier sont
pour une bonne partie d'entre elles en
déclin et le seront dans la décennie
2030 quant au déficit de la balance
commerciale liée aux importations
d'énergie il atteint un record
historique l'exposition de la France à
la volatilité des prix des énergies
fossiles et à la hausse tendancielle
liée à leur déclin n'est pas une
nouveauté lorsque j'étais au
responsabilité le déficit de la balance
commerciale plus de 60 milliards d'euros
à l'époque était au fondement de la
nécessité de planifier la transition
énergétique pour se défaire de ce boulet
des énergies fossiles et être enfin
libre
les énergies fossiles sont la cause du
changement climatique mais aussi de
l'inflation puisque toute matière
première toute marchandise qui est
fabriquée et qui circulent en dépend
quand le pétrole augmente tout augmente
s'y ajoute sur le front des prix de
l'alimentation l'augmentation des dents
et de base provoquées par les impacts du
changement climatique à l'été 2021 là
aussi l'inflation est liée aux impacts
des activités humaines sur le climat je
fais notamment référence aux pertes de
production en céréales liées aux vagues
de chaleur en Amérique du Nord en Europe
en Asie de l'été 2021 donc on a vu les
conséquences sur les marchés mondiaux
dès l'automne 2021 dans le débat public
on évoque souvent les conséquences de
l'inflation or il est nécessaire
d'ouvrir enfin les yeux sur ses causes
et ses causes portent un nom les
énergies fossiles
prévisible aussi étaient les
conséquences de l'absence d'une
politique puissante et efficace
d'économie d'énergie la hausse
structurelle des coûts de l'énergie et
la prévision de hausse future plate de
longue date pour une politique soutenue
de réduction des besoins et de
protection des ménages face à l'impact
social de l'augmentation des prix qu'il
s'agit du carburant pour se déplacer du
gaz ou de l'électricité pour se chauffer
et tous les autres usages de la vie
courante le retard de la France en
matière de réduction de la consommation
d'énergie des radications des passoires
thermiques d'économies d'énergie dans
tous les secteurs d'activités les
bâtiments publics fait gonfler la
facture et seper Cash la précarité
énergétique qui touche de nombreux
ménages frappent désormais les
entreprises et les collectivités locales
qui sont au tarif de marcher ou de
l'électricité du pour l'électricité et
le gaz et sont dans l'incapacité d'y
faire face
j'invite à mettre en regard le coup
astronomique du bouclier tarifaire
comparé aux investissements budgétaires
qui ont été refusés pour les économies
d'énergie dans un passé récent s'ils
avaient été réalisés massivement nous
serions bien plus résilients attendre le
choc pour être mis au pied du mur et
n'avoir d'autres options que de sortir
le carnet de chèque en urgence n'est
assurément pas le bon calcul pour la
nation refuser une politique de
décroissance assumée de la consommation
d'énergie depuis au moins 15 ans a
aujourd'hui des conséquences lourdes et
graves sur le plan social économique et
budgétaire prévisible également sont les
conséquences des règles absurdes du
marché européen de l'électricité qui
prévoit que c'est le dernier moyen
entrer en production qui détermine le
prix et donc que d'une certaine manière
les prix de l'électricité sont indexées
sur le prix du gaz j'y reviendrai
prévisible enfin le fait que la trop
grande dépendance de la France a une
source de production électrique à savoir
le nucléaire est une vulnérabilité la
mise à le cas d'une partie importante du
parc nucléaire en raison d'un défaut
générique et pour raison de sûreté est
un risque énoncé clairement et fortement
depuis longtemps il avait il avait été
notamment par le président de l'Autorité
de sûreté nucléaire dont j'avais proposé
la nomination pierre Franck chevet en
2013 dans l'alerte qu'il avait adressé
dans le cadre du débat national sur la
transition énergétique que je présidais
et qui avait été prise en compte si
ajoute aussi le décalage d'opérations de
maintenance liée à la pandémie ou encore
les dérogations demandées lors de la
sécheresse qui illustre la sensibilité
du nucléaire à des chocs externes les
conséquences sont très lourdes sur le
plan économique et social mais aussi
écologique avec une augmentation du
bilan carbone de l'électricité tous ces
risques étaient donc connus ils sont au
fondement de la nécessité d'une grande
transformation de la politique
énergétique et du pays depuis du pays
depuis longtemps
soit on recherche des boucs émissaires
dans une sorte de jeu politicien du
Mistigri du CEP à moi c'est l'autre et
honnêtement c'est peu c'est de peu
d'intérêt et pour votre commission
d'enquête ce serait beaucoup d'heures de
travail pour rien soit et ce serait
l'intérêt de la nation on peut prendre
un peu de hauteur et de recul et
constaté par delà les alternances et les
changements de ministres nombreuses et
nombreux et certainement trop dans ce
domaine qu'il y a une permanence de
l'inertie française il y a en fait une
ligne de fuite continue dont il faut
examiner les causes profondes la
première est à mes yeux la négation des
limites planétaires et du constat que
nous sommes entrés dans une nouvelle ère
géologique l'anthropocène elle se
caractérise par la destruction un rythme
qui s'accélère des conditions
d'habitabilité de la terre et par
l'épuisement des ressources qui
résultent du mode de civilisation thermo
industrielle actuel elle est porteuse
d'une dynamique d'effondrement
systémique et de tout ce qui nous permet
de vivre climatique risque pour les
éléments de base de la subsistance comme
l'eau et l'alimentation exacerbation des
tensions géopolitiques face à la pénurie
des ressources et son cortège de guerre
conventionnelle ou hybride reconnaître
les réalités de l'anthropocène
impliquent dans finir avec une vision du
monde celle de l'illimitisme dont dans
un monde aux ressources limitées cette
notion de limite physique et le cœur des
enjeux de la politique énergétique or
dans les décisions les limites
planétaires définies par les
scientifiques ne sont pas considérés
comme un déterminant fondamental ni dans
les conséquences que génère la poursuite
de la consommation d'énergie fossile
alors que le nouveau régime climatique
qui en résulte constitue une menace
existentielle sans précédent et sans
équivalent dans l'histoire de l'humanité
ni en termes de contraintes physiques et
de sécurité d'approvisionnement alors
que le pic de pétrole a été franchi en
2008 et que celui du gaz a été franchi
en mettre en Europe et est estimé à
l'horizon 2030 à 2045 au niveau mondial
bref les données de base du nouveau
régime énergétique sont nier le temps du
pétrole pas cher des ressources
illimitées le temps de
l'approvisionnement à flux tendu venant
du bout du monde et depuis sans
étrangères peut fréquentable et
révolution on ne reviendra pas au
capitalisme du 19e siècle ni aux Trent
glorieuses ce n'est ni possible ni
souhaitable si nous souhaitons rester
vivant aussi quand le groupe Total
affirme devant votre commission
d'enquête qu'il n'y a pas de problème de
souveraineté pour la France ou encore
qu'il compte continuer d'exploiter les
énergies fossiles à leur niveau actuel
permettez-moi de dire en tant que membre
de la représentation nationale que c'est
du climato obscurantisme et que ces
criminels sortir des énergies fossiles
est une urgence vitale pour le climat
mais aussi de sécurité nationale pour
nous défaire de dépendance hautement et
assurer la résilience de notre société
face à la hausse du prix des énergies
fossiles
la place centrale qu'occupe le nucléaire
dans le débat sur l'énergie et donc
assez fallacieuse elle occulte en dépit
du plus élémentaire bon sens le
principal l'éléphant dans la pièce à
savoir je le répète que la principale
énergie finale consommée en France et
des sons des énergies fossiles le
nucléaire donne une illusion de confort
qui n'a jamais existé sur l'ensemble de
l'énergie consommée et qui n'existe plus
s'agissant de l'électricité à nouveau le
débat se focalise sur les moyens de
production et parmi eux sur
l'électricité et non sur la demande la
première cause profonde de l'inertie que
j'évoquais et donc le déni ou le
relativisme dont fait preuve la décision
politique à l'égard des connaissances
scientifiques et physiques élémentaires
j'ai cru comprendre que votre commission
s'interroge à ce sujet cette
interrogation est fondée et ce constat
était la vraie pour l'énergie comme dans
de très nombreux domaines je vais en
prendre quelques exemples pour me faire
comprendre
l'horizon de temps de l'état d'urgence
climatique scientifiquement c'est 2030
et non 2050 est-ce qu'on discute des
décisions de politique énergétiques sur
cette base la décision de ré-autoriser
le glyphosate malgré les alertes du
Centre international de recherche sur le
cancer est-elle prise sur une base
scientifique la décision de ré-autoriser
les néonicotinoïdes malgré plus de 1000
études indépendantes sur leur impact
destructeur pour le vivant a été
a-t-elle été prise sur une base
scientifique la décision de lancer un
parc d'EPR 2 dont le design n'est pas
encore achevé alors qu'une des leçons de
l'EPR 1 est précisément l'erreur d'avoir
lancé le projet alors que le design
était inachevé et que pour des réacteurs
qui verraient le jour au mieux en 2040
2045 alors que la question posée je le
répète et de réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2030
une vision prise en dehors de toute
nouvelle programmation globale de la
politique énergétique et ne tenant aucun
compte de ce que sera le climat en 2080
est-elle une décision prise sur la base
d'analyse scientifiques énergétique
technique et industrielle robuste
l'importation de gads de schiste dont le
bilan carbone est pire que celui du
charbon vient un terminal métaniel
récemment autorisé dont le bilan carbone
est lui-même 2,5 fois plus élevé que le
transport par gazoduc est-elle conforme
aux conclusions des rapports du GIEC le
soutien de la France au projet de Total
en Ouganda véritable bombe climatique
est-il conforme aux recommandations de
l'Agence internationale à l'énergie qui
proscrit toute nouvelle exploitation des
énergies fossiles le législateur
lui-même a-t-il tenu compte des
recommandations du Haut Conseil pour le
climat dans ces travaux sur la loi
climat qui en démontrait l'indigence la
réponse est non et je pourrais prolonger
à l'infini la longue liste d'exemples
similaires il faut donc se demander
pourquoi la science n'est pas entendue à
tel point que des scientifiques
s'engagent désormais dans des actions de
désobéissance civile à force de ne plus
savoir comment lancer l'alerte
l'explication est assez simple les
conclusions de la science contrarie une
vision du monde obsolète selon laquelle
la croissance ferait le bonheur elle
contredisent radicalement le
productivisme le consumérisme et par
conséquent de puissante résistance se
dresse face à toute décision prise en
cohérence avec ses connaissances le
ministère de l'écologie et de l'énergie
doit être un ministère de combat parce
qu'obtenir des décisions politiques
fondées sur la science et difficile
c'est son lot quotidien et la cause de
bien des tensions qui l'entourent
j'en viens à la deuxième cause profonde
la nation a perdu la main en l'espace de
20 ans l'édifice de la maîtrise par la
démocratie de la politique énergétique a
été abandonnée pour être confiée à la
main invisible du marché ayons à
l'esprit que jamais la France n'aurait
construit son parc nucléaire si EDF
n'avait pas été une entreprise publique
dont l'endettement était adossé à la
garantie implicite et illimitée de
l'État l'ouverture à la concurrence du
secteur de l'énergie la transformation
des entreprises de services publics en
société anonymes étaient une hérésie ses
choix en générer d'énormes dividendes à
partir des rendent générées par les
investissements consentis de longue date
par la nation là où ils étaient
précédemment réinvestis et partager au
travers des tarifs abordables de
l'énergie les actionnaires ont pris leur
du l'État actionnaire aussi jusqu'en
2015 dans un contexte d'austérité
budgétaire l'entreprise EDF a été abîmée
dans son identité si la culture du
service public
profondément celle de ces agents
auxquels je tiens à rendre hommage
l'ouverture des marchés la séparation
des activités de réseaux de distribution
de production la transformation en
société anonyme n'ont pas été sans
provoquer une déstabilisation profonde
par étape à la façon dont un supplice
chinois puis une fois cela fait il y a
eu le temps de la folie des grandeurs de
la bourse et de l'International de
l'externalisation par la sous-traitance
bien loin du cœur de métier et du
maintien de la performance industrielle
c'est même règle accepter et négocier
par la France à l'échelle européenne ont
aussi fait obstacle à des décisions de
ce que j'avais appelé le patriotisme
écologique afin de soutenir fortement le
développement de filière industrielles
dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables enjeux absolument
déterminant on y reviendra j'imagine
dans la discussion pourquoi confier
l'éolien offshore à une multitude
d'acteurs industriels différents
pourquoi interdire que les capitaux
publics importants engagés dans les
mécanismes de soutien au renouvelables
ne puissent énoncer les plus
élémentaires critères de made in new WAP
ou de Made in France alors que les
panneaux importés de Chine en Europe
étaient vendus à un prix inférieur à 90%
de leur coût de production fallait-il
accepter la capitulation européenne à
cet égard là où nous avions hier les
entreprises de service public nous avons
aujourd'hui une anarchie de développeurs
fournisseur à laquelle plus personne ne
comprend rien et sans retomber
industriel d'ampleur et le comble de
l'absurde et que nous sommes en fait
dans des règles faussement libérales car
le secteur de l'énergie reste en réalité
fortement régulée et que des capitaux
publics importants continuent d'y être
investis nous sommes à la fin d'un cycle
historique le retour de la puissance
publique s'impose et si dès le début des
confinements liés à la pandémie l'Europe
a su suspendre le pacte de stabilité
forcer de constater que près d'un an
après le début de la guerre en Ukraine
elle n'a toujours pas suspendu les
règles du marché européen de
l'électricité le secteur privé ne sera
jamais capable de porter la charge
d'investissement nécessaire à la
politique énergétique dont les cycles de
rentabilité sont longs et l'intensité
capitalistique élevée et à partir du
moment où l'État porte cette charge on
ne voit pas pourquoi il devrait en
partager la rente ces constats ne sont
en fait pas nouveau il m'avait conduit à
refuser la mise en concurrence de la
première source d'électricité
renouvelable de France les barrages
hydrauliques qui sont un actif
stratégique en 2012 et a proposé au
gouvernement dans le cadre de mes
fonctions la mise à l'étude de la
renationalisation d'EDF en 2013
en responsabilité j'ai été très
rapidement arrivée à la conclusion que
cette renationalisation était
incontournable qu'elle devait être
rapide et ce d'ailleurs quel que soit
les choix de politique énergétique
troisième cause la facblissement de
l'État que l'on peut constater dans
toutes les politiques publiques et qui
n'est pas propre à l'énergie mais le
ministère de l'écologie et de l'énergie
ainsi que les directions qu'ils
partagent avec celui du logement et de
la cohésion des territoires selon les
appellations a subi un plan social
massif depuis 15 ans la RGPP et sa
successeur la map modernisation de
l'action publique on détruit plus de
15000 emplois d'agents de l'État et des
opérateurs publics perdre des agents de
l'État dans ce département ministériel
c'est perdre des techniciennes et des
techniciens des ingénieurs qui vont
participer à la conception et à la mise
en oeuvre efficace de la politique
énergétique au niveau central et à la
déployer en lien avec les collectivités
territoriales à l'échelle locale
on peut pas avoir un État fort stratège
agile avec la règle d'un fonctionnaire
sur deux en moins à ce titre la DGEC
malgré la qualité remarquable de ces
agents est clairement sous-dimensionné
pour les défis de la transition
énergétique elle ne peut pas être en
mesure de produire tout ce qui a est
attendu d'elle avec la rapidité
nécessaire elle a une charge de travail
considérable elle est dépendante des
sources d'information des opérateurs et
ne peut pas toujours les
contre-expertiser dans les délais requis
le paradoxe c'est que l'un des éléments
les plus fondamentaux de notre
souveraineté à conquérir l'énergie et de
notre sécurité dans le chaos climatique
qui vient l'écologie n'est toujours pas
considéré comme un ministère régalien
avoir récemment cassé ce grand ministère
en séparant l'énergie de l'adaptation au
changement climatique et d'une approche
systémique de l'ensemble des enjeux
écologiques ne contribue pas à la force
de la puissance publique dans ces
domaines
quatrième cause une forme de
confiscation démocratique hautement
problématique
historiquement sous la Cinquième
République le nucléaire et le domaine
réservé du président de la République
notamment en raison du lien entre une
nucléaire civile et militaire mais c'est
aussi vrai bien sûr pour le pétrole et
le gaz et par extension pour l'ensemble
de la politique énergétique l'énergie
reste une sorte de domaine de la raison
d'État cela explique un manque de
culture démocratique qui joue un rôle
central dans la perte de souveraineté
qui est au centre des travaux de votre
commission d'enquête il règne dans
l'énergie un entre soi et un élitisme
puissant qui implique que l'on traite
avec paternalisme la vie des citoyennes
et des citoyens des élus de la
représentation nationale des ministres
cette culture
issue des institutions présidentialistes
de la 5ème a formé un cocktail détonnant
hautement problématique une fois que les
entreprises EDF GDF ELF par le passé
sont devenus des entreprises privées
depuis lors la relation entre ces
entreprises et la France au travers de
ces représentants est ambigu dans une
savante confusion entre éthique de
l'État et intérêt privé d'autant que en
même temps que les entreprises étaient
partiellement ou totalement privatisées
la haute fonction publique était dominée
par la fascination de l'appel du secteur
privé le pantouflage et le rétrop
pantouflage qui décide dans le domaine
de l'énergie et qui décide de quoi étant
entendu que chacun devrait être à sa
place ce n'est pas aux industriels de
décider des objectifs de la politique
énergétique de la nation même si leur
contrainte et leur réalité peuvent être
prises en compte et ce n'est pas à
l'état de dire quel type de produit ou
de choix industriels doit être fait pour
les pour atteindre les objectifs fixés
chacun son métier mais qui décide quand
les opérateurs continuent d'avoir besoin
de décision diverses de tout en se
considérant désormais comme épan
émanciper voire supérieur au gouvernant
ou autorisé à louvoyer avec la décision
publique lorsqu'ils ont besoin de l'État
ils savent le trouver lorsque l'État est
non une décision qui contrarie une
vision conservatrice il rappelle qu'ils
ont des actionnaires et que la bourse ne
sera pas d'accord voire il la combatte
publiquement ce cocktail rend difficile
pour les gouvernements l'exercice de
leur prérogative en matière de politique
énergétique a fortiori quand le débat
démocratique en temps fixé un nouveau
cap
ce constat va au-delà d'une habituelle
résistance au changement car ces
opérateurs ont bénéficié d'une sorte de
logique de passe droite tel qu'il semble
s'étonner lorsque les plus élémentaires
exigences de performance industrielle
sont attendues d'eux qu'il s'agisse par
exemple du retard de l'EPR de
Flamanville ou du scandale des Forges du
Creusot j'ajoute que l'interview donnait
ce matin par le PDG de Total est à
l'image de la prétention d'une sorte de
caste énergétique à s'exonérer de ses
responsabilités et à prétendre gouverner
ce mélange des genres et celui auquel
j'ai été confronté aux responsabilités
je ne vois pas en quoi il entre dans les
prérogatives du PDG de Total de
criminaliser la jeunesse qui dénonce ses
projets climaticides ni au nom de quoi
le PDG de Total s'autorise à interférer
dans le débat politique national pour
soutenir la réforme du gouvernement sur
le report de l'âge légal de la retraite
s'ajoute à ce tableau un constat à mes
yeux important pour vos travaux
beaucoup s'imaginent sans doute que le
secteur du pétrole et celui du nucléaire
ne défende pas les mêmes options dans
les coulisses du pouvoir exerce des
influences contradictoires auprès des
décides et des décideurs bien sûr il
existe des points de friction mais la
réalité est tout autre mon expérience de
ce couple dominant pétrole nucléaire et
qu'il se retrouve souvent en bras dessus
bras dessous sur le sensiel sur
l'essentiel pour le conservatisme
énergétique
il prône la continuité de la politique
énergétique alors que tout a changé leur
relais technocratique comme politique
défendait quand j'étais ministre et le
gaz de schiste et le nucléaire et le
pétrole et le gaz il met il militait
conjointement contre les renouvelables
vu comme une politique superficielle
pour l'affichage et non comme un enjeu
industriel auquel il ne croyait pas mais
sur le tout il s'assemblait sur le fond
pour combattre toute politique
rigoureuse d'économie d'énergie et une
donnée scientifique indiscutable il n'y
a pas de feuilles de route pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone qui ne
commence par diviser par deux la
consommation d'énergie en France il n'y
a pas de plan B à la réduction de la
demande la question centrale et donc de
reprendre le contrôle de la politique
énergétique ce que je dis aujourd'hui à
votre commission n'est pas nouveau c'est
ce qui a guidé mes décisions et
orientations aux responsabilités et qui
a donné lieu à un intitulé de la
souveraineté énergétique dans le livre
que j'ai écrit sur l'exercice du pouvoir
il expliquait en quoi le statu quo
n'était pas une option et en quoi la
nation devait reprendre la main
l'article 3 de la Constitution définit
la souveraineté en ce qu'elle appartient
au peuple qu'il exerce par ses
représentants qui ajoutent qu'aucune
section du peuple ni aucun individu ne
peut s'en attribuer l'exercice sa lettre
et son esprit sont-ils respectés dans le
domaine de l'énergie la réponse est non
merci beaucoup madame la ministre alors
on va essayer dans notre audition de se
concentrer surtout sur la période
pendant laquelle vous avez exercé vos
responsabilités et du coup je me permets
de vous relancer sur ce qui était
finalement mon propos introductif
le
débat national sur la transition
énergétique que vous avez lancée et
piloter est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire deux mots sur les objectifs qui
étaient les siens sur la façon dont tout
cela a fonctionné et atterri
tout à fait
pour comprendre peut-être
ce débat il faut revenir à l'objectif
donc pardon oui tout à fait mais j'ai
bien compris le sens de votre question
donc l'engagement
du président de la République François
Hollande
qui est figurait dans son programme
présidentiel c'était d'engager la
transition énergétique avec des éléments
d'économie d'énergie de diminution de la
consommation des énergies fossiles de
développement des énergies renouvelables
et l'objectif de diminuer à 50% la part
du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité à l'horizon 2025 cet
objectif a été approuvé par le peuple
français lors de lors de l'élection
présidentielle je rappelle que la
question de l'avenir du nucléaire avait
été un élément important du débat
démocratique Nicolas Sarkozy avait fait
campagne sur ce sujet y compris avec des
meetings dans des centrales électorales
ce qui devrait d'ailleurs être un sujet
en tant que tel car une entreprise
publique n'a pas franchement interférer
dans une campagne électorale
je sais que vous interrogez cette cet
objectif de 50% je voudrais faire
remarquer qu'il est curieux au regard de
l'article 3 de la Constitution que je
viens de rappeler car raisonnement sur
la souveraineté énergétique comment par
contester une décision souveraine du
peuple français de changer de politique
énergétique parlementaire confié à ses
représentants cet objectif il résultat
du programme présidentiel qu'il
résultait lui-même d'un accord entre le
Parti socialiste et les Verts et là
aussi je ferai remarquer que je ne sais
pas depuis quand il faut s'excuser de
vouloir mettre en œuvre le programme
pour lequel on a été élu
sur le fond cet objectif
est un bon objectif dans l'intérêt de la
nation car la trop grande dépendance de
la France au nucléaire pour son
électricité est une vulnérabilité comme
les faits viennent de le nez le
démontrer la diversification
des moyens de production électrique et
l'intérêt de la France l'autre élément
qui est au centre des questions qui
entourent le parc nucléaire depuis des
années c'est l'effet de Falaise c'est à
dire la charge d'investissement que
représente la fin de vie des réacteurs à
40 ans dans un pas de temps réduit face
auquel un choix responsable n'est pas de
reporter le mur à plus loin mais de
chercher à le lycée en fermant des
réacteurs et en en prolongeant d'autres
l'enjeu du quinquennat de François
Hollande était donc de prendre des
décisions concernant l'avenir du parc
nucléaire l'engagement pour y parvenir
était
celui d'une loi de programmation à
l'équivalent de ce qu'est une loi de
programmation militaire et donc le débat
national sur la transition énergétique
qui diffère des
différents débats dont vous avez rappelé
l'historique en ce qu'il n'était ni que
un débat d'experts ni que un débat de
parties prenantes mais aussi un débat
citoyen et dans les dans les territoires
partaient du constat d'un relatif échec
du Grenelle de l'environnement c'est à
dire qu'il ne suffit pas dénoncer des
objectifs pour les atteindre et qu'il
faut planifier organiser y compris les
moyens
dans la façon dont
la nation va organiser sa transition
énergétique donc en fait on était dans
une situation pour le quinquennat les
choses étaient cadrées c'était la
fermeture de Fessenheim et l'ouverture
de l'EPR de comme vous le savez n'a pas
ouvert et où pour sur un pas de temps de
10 ans à 15 ans une loi de programmation
équivalente à une noix de programmation
militaire avec des clauses de revoyure
était adoptée pour organiser
les économies d'énergie le développement
des renouvelables la sortie des fossiles
et la diminution du nucléaire
j'en viens à la mise en oeuvre
les différentes études que j'ai fait
faire au service
montrer que la diminution à 50% du
nucléaire dans l'électricité pouvait
être atteinte en 2028 à 2030 de façon
réaliste mais que la date de 2025 qu'il
était aussi possible d'atteindre n'était
pas souhaitable car elle obligerait à
recourir aux énergies fossiles en
remplacement du nucléaire ce n'était pas
mon option je l'ai toujours dit car
j'affirmais comme ministre un modèle
français de transition énergétique avec
l'ordre des priorités suivantes un des
économies d'énergie massive de la sortie
des énergies fossiles 3 la
diversification et la diminution du
nucléaire par un développement massif
des énergies renouvelables pour moi il
fallait fermer des réacteurs à mesure
que des progrès étaient accomplis sur
les l'économie d'énergie la sortie des
énergies fossiles et le développement
des énergies renouvelables comme je l'ai
déjà écrit j'ai soumis début 2013 au
président de la République la
possibilité
d'inscrire dans les conclusions du débat
national sur la transition énergétique
et ensuite dans le projet de loi qui
serait soumis au Parlement de
programmation de traduire juridiquement
ce que je viens dénoncer avec un
calendrier précis documenté et réaliste
il ne l'a pas souhaité par la suite
comme vous le savez j'ai quitté les
responsabilités avant la conclusion du
débat national sur la transition
énergétique et il n'y a pas eu de loi de
programmation il n'y a pas eu même de
recommandations du débat national sur la
transition énergétique puisque le Medef
a jugé inacceptable que soit recommandée
la division par deux de la consommation
d'énergie les conclusions de 7 mois de
travaux qui ont mobilisé un nombre
considérable de personnes et
d'intelligence ce sont donc résumés à
une simple synthèse des échanges par
parenthèse le choix politique qui va
avait été fait à nous vergeon à
participer au comité de pilotage tout
comme Bruno Rebelle qui a été précemment
précédemment directeur général de
Greenpeace était de ne pas organiser un
débat national sur l'énergie comme le
Grenelle en considérant que le nucléaire
était un tabou et qu'on ne pouvait pas
en discuter donc oui il y avait
d'ardents militants du nucléaire et
d'ardent militants de la sortie du
nucléaire qui était parti prenante du
débat national évidemment la loi de 2015
qui a été adoptée a énoncé donc des
objectifs de façon déclammatoire
dans la continuité du Grenelle sans
préciser ni le calendrier ni les moyens
de les atteindre dans le domaine de
l'évolution du parc nucléaire comme dans
d'autres elle a par exemple ce qui n'est
pas un détail reportée de 10 ans
l'objectif de réduction de la
consommation d'énergie de 2020 à 2030
elle a confié la planification à
l'exécutif seul au travers d'une PPE par
décret laquelle renvoyait à 2019 après
le quinquennat les arbitrages sur
l'avenir du parc nucléaire on est donc
très loin d'une loi de programmation en
ce qui concerne le nucléaire la loi
énonce l'objectif de 50% mais la vraie
disposition normative gèle le parc à son
niveau actuel 63,2 gigawatts ce
dispositif donne en lieu à une multitude
d'interprétations chacune et chacun y
voyant des vérités différentes certains
pouvaient y voir une intention réelle de
diminuer le nucléaire voir un point de
passage vers la sortie d'autres le
comprenaient pour ce qu'il est au regard
de sa portée juridique à savoir un
renoncement à la réduction et un
plafonnement et un statu quo d'autres
enfin pouvaient faire toute une série de
conjectures comme celle de l'addition
énergétique c'est-à-dire que la
consommation augmentant et les énergies
renouvelables se développant les 63,2
gigawatts représenterait les 50%.
d'autres encore oubliés que le texte
mentionne la production d'électricité et
pouvait imaginer que c'était 50% en
consommation intérieure d'électricité ce
qui n'interdirait pas d'utiliser les
63,2 gigawatts pour exporter bref
c'était plus ambigu l'ensemble de ces
raisons m'ont amené étant redevenu
député à ne pas voter cette loi et
j'avais eu l'occasion de déplorer un
enterrement de première classe de la
transition énergétique et de dire que de
ne pas prendre de décision à l'époque
promettait de grandes difficultés à
l'avenir
jusque là vous avez plutôt bien retracé
la succession des
échanges que nous avons pu avoir dans
notre commission d'enquête
j'en viens à une
question
m'inspirée par mode votre propos
luminaire
je partage l'idée que
l'énergie est au cœur du système
économique et donc de l'inflation
par contre je comprends pas forcément
complètement ce que vous avez dit dans
la mesure où la question du prix de
l'énergie évidemment déterminé par le
marché enfin je reste sur les faux cils
le marché des changes international
également par une part de volonté
politique
d'exercices de fiscalité sur sur le
pétrole et sur le gaz
de ce point de vue là comment est-ce que
vous avez à prendre appréhendé cela dans
une logique de transition ou autre sur
un marché qui finalement en matière de
sécurité d'approvisionnement
grâce à la stabilité des produits
semblait donner un certain nombre de
garanties je sais pas quelle est la
lecture que que vous faisiez de ces
sujets là donc comment est-ce que vous
avez agi ou
appréhender d'agir sur les questions du
prix des énergies fossiles
j'essaye de comprendre le sens de votre
question
donc moi ma vision je pense qu'il
devrait être celle de tout le monde
c'est qu'il faut sortir des énergies
fossiles le plus vite possible donc ne
pas rester dans cette dans cette logique
de dépendance votre question c'est sur
les c'est sur la fiscalité sur les en
fait je repartais du de votre
raisonnement en disant bon on a une
question de
souveraineté d'indépendance
l'indépendance sur les énergies fossiles
n'est pas acquises complètement d'accord
la souveraineté elle est en quelque
sorte assurée par des règles de de
stockage de de stock stratégique qui
sont sur ces biens stockables
contrairement l'électricité qui est
peut-être un peu moins illusion de
société il y a deux dimensions par
pardon je clarifie ma question puisque
vous me le demandez
et vous dites ensuite le sujet c'est que
l'énergie elle est au cœur de du système
inflationniste donc comment est-ce qu'on
finalement dans votre modèle
que je rejette pas en bloc d'ailleurs
j'ai pas émis de vous agresser j'ai pas
aimé de d'objections quand au modèle que
vous défendez
comment est-ce que vous organisez d'un
point de vue du prix la transition entre
entre les entre les deux modèles le
modèle dans lequel on était en 2012
quand vous avez pris vos affaires dans
lequel on est sûrement encore
aujourd'hui et puis le modèle
davantage des carbonés moins dépendant
du pétrole et du gaz
est-ce que la question de l'augmentation
du prix est le passage obligé et donc la
génération d'inflation alors d'abord ce
qu'il faut rappeler c'est que en 2012 on
est dans le contexte que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure de l'après crise de 2008 et
donc d'une flambée des prix des
carburant et que donc on est très
concrètement confronté moi je suis élu
en plus d'un territoire rural donc on
est confronté
à une situation qui est assez comparable
à ce qui a été vécu dans la période
récente sur le sur le prix des
carburants juste une injuste une insiste
je pense que c'est important de pas
confondre
les éléments par lesquels la France
tente d'avoir une relative sécurité
d'approvisionnement sur les énergies
fossiles diversification des pays auprès
desquels la France s'approvisionne
stockage etc avec de la souveraineté
on dépend entièrement de produits qui
sont des produits qui sont des produits
importés
je n'arrive pas à comprendre en fait
excusez-moi de vous demander de préciser
si la dimension de votre question c'est
à quel point le budget de l'État dépend
de la fiscalité sur les énergies
fossiles ou si c'est une autre question
c'est pour ça
pas du tout sur le budget de l'État au
contraire mais c'est pourtant un sujet
réel mais
je ne dis pas l'inverse
mais dans votre propos introductif vous
avez longuement insisté sur le fait que
la situation dans laquelle on est
actuellement c'est une situation qui est
liée
l'inflation j'entends que la cause elle
est dans la dépendance dans la
dépendance des énergies carbonées
comment est-ce que vous avez agi sur ce
sujet là notamment d'un point de vue du
prix puisque c'est ça qui génère
l'inflation non c'est pas le c'est pas
c'est pas la question c'est pas d'agir
sur le sur les prix la question c'est
d'agir sur la consommation du produit
donc c'est d'agir sur la demande
il y a pas d'autres il y a pas d'autre
schémas après bien évidemment on peut
prendre toutes les mesures que l'on veut
sur la sur la régulation du prix le
problème c'est le point de départ du
sujet donc c'est la consommation
d'énergie fossile pour se chauffer pour
ce pour se déplacer prioritairement
d'où l'importance que j'ai développé
d'une politique de réduction et de
décroissance de la demande en énergie
donc pour la réduction des de la demande
d'énergie
pas sur la question par exemple le
bâtiment quand vous devenez ministre le
droit applicable c'est la RT 2012
il me semble mais je peux me tromper que
la RT20 20 est déjà un peu dans les
tuyaux
comment est-ce que vous vous agissez sur
les sujets pour finalement accélérer les
les économies d'énergie dans votre
propos introductif vous avez dit les
investissements sur les économies
d'énergie ont été refusées parce que
vous pouvez peut-être préciser ça oui
tout à fait
donc sur d'abord votre question sur la
RT
2012 elle est elle est
issue du Grenelle si ma mémoire est
bonne mais je ne veux pas être
approximative devant votre commission
c'est bon un élément central du débat
national sur la sur la transition
énergétique et l'éradication de la
précarité énergétique
à l'époque on est dans une augmentation
extrêmement forte de cet enjeu et donc
il y a plusieurs éléments de la
politique que nous voulons déployer qui
dans notre action vraiment je veux
insister dessus est un élément enfin et
le pilier j'allais dire premier
principal etc donc il y a un premier
élément qui est celui du bonus malus
c'est à dire de la mise en place
peut-être c'était ça à votre question
mais elle est pas sur les que sur les
énergies fossiles c'est à dire d'un
changement tarifaire mettant en place
une logique de bonus malus c'est à dire
d'une d'un mécanisme sur les prix qui
fait que quand on consomme peu d'énergie
il est un tarif moins cher et que dès
qu'on en consomme moyennement il est
plus cher et si on en consomme beaucoup
de façon déraisonnable par rapport à ce
qui est la consommation d'un ménage à ce
moment là les tarifs augmentent de façon
conséquente c'est ce que nous avions mis
dans la proposition de loi qui avait été
défendue par François brode devant
l'Assemblée nationale et qui a été
censurée par le Conseil constitutionnel
sur la base d'un recours du groupe
UMP à l'époque non pas
sur le principe la censure juste pour
expliquer non pas sur le principe du
bonus malus mais
sur
le fait que quand on souhaitait le
déployer il y avait toute une série de
situations particulières par exemple par
rapport au chauffage collectif etc qui
entraînait dans les dispositions du
texte que le Conseil constitutionnel a
considéré qu'on était en rupture avec le
principe d'égalité inscrit dans dans la
Constitution donc ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose est donc ça a
été un échec important l'échec du bonus
malus sur lequel il n'y avait pas
de nouvelles options législatives compte
tenues de la problème du principe du
problème du principe d'égalité il y
avait pas d'autres options législatives
pour pour y revenir
et la solution
sur laquelle j'ai travaillé par la suite
c'est une un mécanisme en fait de
modulation tarifaire à l'image de ce qui
existe aujourd'hui entre hors planeur
choses etc
susceptible notamment d'avoir un effet
sur la problématique de la pointe
puisque
comme comme vous le savez elle avait
augmenté si ma mémoire est bonne de 68%
la pointe électrique au cours des 10
années précédentes donc ce qui est
absolument considérable
donc
nous avons ensuite
étendu les tarifs sociaux de l'énergie à
8 millions de de ménage en ce qui
concerne la RT 2012 et l'ensemble des
éléments liés à la rénovation et à la
performance énergétique c'était un
élément central du débat national sur la
transition énergétique avec la volonté
de mettre en place
un mécanisme de rénovation
performante très fortement soutenue par
les pouvoirs publics nous avons arraché
avec la ministre
facile Duflot après un combat homérique
la baisse de 5 la baisse de la TVA sur
les travaux d'efficacité énergétique à
5%
pour le reste
ce que j'ai constaté
c'est
la façon dont Bercy et le ministère des
Finances et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je faisais la remarque que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure de comparaison avec
les coûts du bouclier tarifaire actuel
refuse en fait une logique
d'investissement dans les économies
d'énergie par exemple sur la TVA il ne
voulait pas admettre le raisonnement qui
avait pourtant quand même été démontré
par la baisse de TVA qui avait fait
précédemment le gouvernement de Lionel
Jospin ou il était
absolument pas contestable qu'en
baissant la TVA il y avait eu plus
d'activités que du coup il y avait eu
plus de travaux il y a eu plus
d'activités économiques et il y avait eu
plus au final de recettes fiscales de
TVA ce type de raisonnement là
c'est à dire le fait que des
investissements ont un coût budgétaire
mais son rentable ne sont pas du tout
ceux de Bercy qui depuis des années à
déployé une très grande compétence dans
le fait de faire changer chaque année ou
presque les mécanismes de soutien public
aux travaux d'efficacité énergétique
dans les logements ce qui ce qui tue
tout efficacité de politique publique en
la matière parce que chaque année les
artisans doivent savoir ce qu'est ce qui
a changé etc etc enfin on s'arrache les
cheveux
et par la suite comme vous le savez
les choix qui ont été faits étaient ceux
de l'austérité budgétaire et donc
l'austérité budgétaire qui
a entraîné la diminution de 7% du budget
du ministère de l'Écologie et mon départ
du gouvernement visé aussi les choix
d'investissement dans les économies
d'énergie qui n'ont pas été consenties à
ce moment là
merci bien
j'en viens à la question des énergies
renouvelables
quelles ont été un finalement vos
grandes vos grands objectifs les moyens
que vous avez mis en place vos résultats
en matière d'énergie renouvelable et
notamment de mise en place d'une
industrie des énergies renouvelables à
la maille européenne
voire de ce point de vue là
ok alors
sur les énergies renouvelables d'abord
peut-être pour pour décrire
la situation
je veux faire juste noter que je suis
pour la proposition de loi qui est en
train d'être discuté en ce moment en
séance que je suis pour la
nationalisation d'EDF et pour
le rétablissement des tarifs réglementés
pour les entreprises et les
collectivités territoriales mais je
continue à répondre à vos questions donc
sur les énergies renouvelables sur les
énergies renouvelables la situation
que que nous trouvons
en arrivant
est objectivement
par réjouissante
14.000 emplois ont été supprimés dans le
solaire et le photovoltaïque le tarif de
rachat de l'éolien
risque d'être suspendu dans le cadre
d'un contentieux devant la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne
il y a une ribambelle de contentieux
entourant les projets éoliens liés au
fait qu'il y a eu nombre de conflits
d'intérêts à l'échelle locale dans la
définition des aides
ainsi de suite enfin je peux je peux
développer et surtout si je prends
l'exemple du solaire on a plus d'un
milliard d'euros de déficits de la
balance commerciale
liée aux importations de panneaux
solaires qui avaient entraîné le
moratoire moratoire qui a détruit 14 000
emplois donc sous le sous le précédent
gouvernement donc le choix que nous
faisons immédiatement ce que j'ai appelé
le patriotisme écologique c'est
plusieurs choses j'espère ne rien
oublier dans ce que je vais vous dire
d'abord c'est que les énergies
renouvelables en France c'est pas que
les énergies électriques
et cette question est absolument
fondamentale
la question de la chaleur renouvelable
et certainement dans les années à venir
du froid renouvelable et central et donc
il y a une manière il me semble
d'enfermer le débat en fait quand on
parle du nucléaire des renouvelables du
mix etc dans une confusion entre mix et
électrique et mix énergétique et donc on
doit aujourd'hui
transférer des usages de l'électricité
vers des énergies renouvelables
non électrique et on doit transférer des
usages des énergies fossiles vers
l'électricité
il y a un transfert de l'usage d'usage
du fossile vers l'électricité dans un
certain nombre de domaines donc pour moi
la et donc mon premier acte en tant que
en tant que ministre
a été en direction notamment des sujets
liés à la biomasse et à la problématique
du fond chaleur qui est une des victimes
des arbitrages budgétaires qui ont
entraîné mon départ du gouvernement
le fond chaleur de la dame qui soutient
donc la chaleur renouvelable et qui est
un dispositif important donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième c'est ce que
j'ai appelé le patriotisme écologique
c'est-à-dire que les soutiens publics
dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables doivent se traduire par
des structuration de filières
industrielles en fait on avait fait
faire avec Arnaud Montebourg un rapport
au cége donc le corps d'administration
de l'industrie et de l'énergie sur
justement cette problématique des
filières industrielles qui n'étaient pas
réjouissant rapport qui avait été mis en
débat dans la conférence
environnementale de septembre 2012 et
par la suite en fait ce que j'avais à
traiter si vous voulez c'est qu'il y
avait le débat national sur la
transition énergétique avec donc la loi
de programmation à venir qui pour moi
j'y reviendrai devait entièrement
changer les règles du jeu sur les
énergies renouvelables et en même temps
il y avait une situation critique d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui m'a amené
donc à prendre ce que j'ai appelé des
mesures d'urgence notamment pour pour le
solaire et pour l'éolien pour l'éolien
ce sont les dispositions qui ont été
inscrites dans la loi Brotte de
suppression des ade mais ça a été aussi
d'obtenir du commissaire européen
almounia
que
le tarif de rachat de l'électricité et
éolien soit considérés comme une aide
d'État compatible avec les règles de la
concurrence je me souviendrai d'ailleurs
toujours de ce que le commissaire
européen m'a dit lorsque je suis allé le
voir
puisque en gros il m'a dit oh la
ministre française je peux vous faire
sourire oh la ministre française que je
suis heureux qu'une ministre française
vienne me voir vous savez que les
ministres allemands dorment devant ma
porte
et il m'a dit quoi que vous me demandiez
c'est oui parce que vous êtes venus me
voir voilà et donc en fait ce qu'on a
fait était très simple c'est à dire que
comme on savait que le les actes
juridiques
du tarif éolien allait être cassé par la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne en
fait j'ai publié avant que l'ancien
texte soit
caduque un nouveau un nouveau texte
avant ou juste après je me souviens plus
qui était acté par par la Commission
européenne
sur le solaire
donc il restait très peu d'acteurs en
France
et
outre la mécanique des appels d'offres
sur laquelle je reviendrai
j'ai introduit
non sans une bataille là aussi
rude
un
une bonification
lorsque les panneaux achetés étaient
fabriqués en Europe cette bonification a
été supprimée en avril 2015
le simple fait d'adopter ce mécanisme de
bonification
a demandé d'obtenir en fait l'arbitrage
pour cette bonification à demander
énormément
d'énergie et
Bercy
n'y était pas favorable donc ça a pas
été un arbitrage facile à gagner et ce
tarif a été supprimé par la suite
sur l'éolien offshore le constat que
j'ai fait immédiatement c'est de ne pas
comprendre
pourquoi
il y avait un acteur industriel
différent par projet
et je vois pas comment on peut
structurer
une filière industrielle puissante
en dispersant
la compétence industrielle avec tous les
problèmes techniques
liés à l'éolien au Chorges juridique etc
en une multitude d'acteurs
pour moi l'éolien offshore si vous
voulez c'est l'exemple même de
l'absurdité des principes d'ouverture à
la concurrence en fait soit la France
veut avoir un acteur de l'éolien
offshore et puis il s'occupe de tous les
parcs là le caractère dispersé à mon
avis est une partie de l'explication du
retard ensuite dans la dans le
déploiement
des choses
donc j'ai dit pour l'éolien pour le
solaire pour le renouvelable pour la
chaleur renouvelable
ensuite sur le je sais pas si j'oublie
quelque chose vous me le direz
sur sur le
ma conception des mécanismes
en fait à cette époque on voit on voit
les problèmes sont énormes on a une
dette de 5 milliards de CSPE
d'engagement sur les énergies
renouvelables non compensées
à EDF
on a une mécanique
des tarifs de rachat sur 20 ans etc
qui est problématique on a une mécanique
des appels d'offres qui malgré la pour
certains appels d'offres le caractère
prévisible pour d'autres ce n'est pas le
cas et donc voyez une absence de
prévisibilité à long terme pour les
acteurs industriels qui est
objectivement un problème sur le solaire
j'ai oublié de dire que j'ai supprimé la
mécanique qui favorisait les projets
solaires sur surface agricole etc
j'ai cassé cette logique là
volontairement et je l'assume
donc en fait moi pour moi cette
mécanique ne va pas
et elle devait être changer avec la loi
de programmation pour la transition
énergétique je pense que des mécanismes
de soutien budgétaire direct à
l'investissement
avec par ailleurs une planification
territoriale des implantations
c'est à dire appliquer aux énergies
renouvelables la culture du service
public et de l'établissement public
aurait été une mécanique beaucoup plus
structurante en termes de filières
industrielles et avec beaucoup plus de
résultats beaucoup plus de résultats que
l'anarchie actuelle en fait dans le
développement des énergies renouvelables
développer un acteur industriel
nécessité aussi à mes yeux de vouloir
fabriquer un ou des champions européens
et donc c'est tous les échanges
essayant d'aller vers la constitution
d'un Airbus du renouvelable
et donc les échanges à l'échelle
européenne
notamment avec l'Allemagne
dans une situation où avec le ministre
allemand nous étions à respectueux des
choix de mix électrique différents entre
la France et l'Allemagne mais nous
voyons bien que nous avions des
problématiques communes et donc il nous
fallait agir pour essayer de créer une
alliance à l'échelle européenne sur
un sujet très déterminant qui est assez
technique mais qu'on appelle le
backlogding c'est à dire qu'à l'époque
le prix du carbone était
désespérément bas et que ça avait des
conséquences très très lourdes donc il
fallait obtenir de la Commission
européenne qu'elle supprime en fait un
certain nombre de quotas qui ne valait
rien pour faire remonter le prix du CO2
et la deuxième c'est qu'on était
convaincu l'un comme l'autre qu'il
fallait aller vers la création d'une
sorte de zone euro de l'énergie
c'est à dire d'une coopération
renforcée pas à l'échelle des 28 mais
d'une zone euro de l'énergie avec un
prix unique du carbone avec une sécurité
d'approvisionnement
[Musique]
commune avec un mécanisme de capacité
commun et avec
une stratégie
visant à se débarrasser des dépendances
aux énergies fossiles et à développer
une industrie des énergies renouvelables
sur le mécanisme de capacité
c'est un élément important que j'ai
oublié tout à l'heure dans l'action sur
la demande
puisque en fait
nous avons pris différentes mesures en
faveur de l'effacement de l'interrupteur
l'intérusabilité j'ai jamais subi de le
dire donc c'est ça a pas changé
donc ça c'est un élément important en
fait notamment parce que on a les
rapports
de RTE donc je ne sais plus si c'est le
rapport 2011 ou le rapport 2012 qui
annonce
une tension
pour 2015 2016 une vraie problématique
pour 2017 et donc on a besoin de
développer le l'effacement de mettre en
place le mécanisme de capacité donc
c'est un décret je crois en décembre
qui vise
pas mettre en place
une sécurité à la fois sur des sources
de production et en même temps
d'effacement je dois dire
que lorsque la France
a voulu mettre en place le mécanisme de
capacité
il a fallu convaincre la Commission
européenne que ce n'était pas le retour
de la régulation
par un des chapitres de la mise en
oeuvre de la loi norme que par ailleurs
je n'avais pas voté avec laquelle je
n'étais je n'étais pas d'accord comme
député précédemment
et donc voilà il y a eu un nombre
d'échanges importants sur cette question
du mécanisme de capacité parce que son
principe même
contredit une logique de laisser faire
et de marcher en obligeant
à garantir des capacités de production
et des capacités d'effacement
c'était problématique pour l'Union
européenne dans les deux cas
c'est-à-dire production et effacement
qu'il faudrait poser la question
monsieur Abadie parce que c'est c'est
lui qui a je ne préfère pas vous faire
des réponses à peu près
je pense surtout sur l'aspect
capacité de production voilà mais je
vous dis ça de mémoire et
bah du coup je reviens pour moi une
dernière question après je laisserai la
parole à porteur sur la reine vous avez
dit quand vous étiez préalablement
député vous n'avez pas voté
est-ce que du coup c'est un sujet qui
était une un sujet de préoccupation
lorsque vous étiez ministre est-ce que
vous avez eu des alertes sur la question
du prix
où c'était pas un sujet finalement
j'ai pas d'alerte j'ai le récit par
Henri poglio de la façon dont a été
déterminé le tarif et la négociation qui
a eu lieu
je trouve un secteur d'EDF et notamment
ses organisations syndicales très
mécontents de ce dispositif un PDG qui
lui trouve que l'un dans l'autre
c'est comme ça et puis c'est très récent
donc les lourdes alertes que nous avons
à l'époque concernant la trajectoire
tarifaire d'EDF c'est sur le tard c'est
sur le tarif réglementé c'est sur le
tarif payé j'adhère par tout le monde
par les par les ménages plus que sur
l'arène
ensuite ce sujet revient en fait au
travers du mécanisme de capacité d'une
part et d'autre part
indirectement
par la problématique des électrons
intensifs
car en fait on se trouve
surtout on commence à être en 2012-2013
dans une situation où
il y a un écart
par rapport à ce qui a été longtemps
l'avantage d'un certain nombre
d'industries hautement consommatrices
d'électricité en France par rapport au
prix de l'électricité en Allemagne en
fait l'Allemagne a pris des mesures
valider d'ailleurs à l'échelle
européenne permettant que que ces
industries bénéficient d'un tarif qui
est en train de devenir moins cher que
le tarif de l'électricité en France pour
les entreprises et donc ce qui m'a
conduit à faire voter au Parlement
différentes dispositions puisque un
certain nombre d'industriels étaient
prisonniers d'un mécanisme qui s'appelle
excelsium qui était plus cher que la
reine voilà mais non il y a pas à cette
époque là j'avais beaucoup d'échanges
avec la creux j'ai pas d'alerte sur le
prix de la rentrée par rapport rapport à
ce moment là j'ai par contre un grave
problème de tarif pour les ménages
celle qui vous a succédé
nous a dit que la reine je suis vraiment
pas un sujet enfin pas du tout monté au
niveau ministériel donc c'était pas un
sujet d'alerte ça je le comprends de vos
propos les tarifs finalement collés à la
à la réalité du marché à ce moment-là
est-ce que c'était quand même un sujet
d'attention qui était d'ordre
ministériel ou c'est vraiment votre
implication particulière sur les
dossiers qui fait enfin sur ce dossier
de l'énergie qui fait que vous en aviez
une connaissance
c'est à dire est-ce que si vous n'avez
pas fié fait dans votre dans l'exercice
de votre fonction ministérielle
l'objet de d'une attention très
particulière sur la question de
l'énergie et des mécanismes de marché de
l'énergie est-ce que la question de la
reine serait quelque chose qui vous
serait naturellement remonté par par les
services
ah oui ce serait remonté
ce serait remonté chaque rapport de la
creux
oui si je c'est pour ça que je vous dis
que je pense qu'il y a pas eu du tout
enfin compte que cette période là n'est
pas une période où il y a une alerte sur
ce sur ce sujet parce que
j'ai demandé un audit à la Creuse sur
les coûts de production d'EDF
et donc je pense que si je m'en
souviendrai je me souviendrai s'il y
avait eu une alerte sur le
temps par rapport à
c'est pas tant par rapport à vous dans
ce que vous vous avez fait ou autre
c'est plus pour comprendre comment ça
fonctionne au niveau ministériel le
traitement d'un sujet comme celui-là
c'est à dire est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui remonte quand il y a un
problème
et là en l'occurrence vous dites grosso
modo c'est une période sur laquelle la
reine pose pas de problème d'un point de
vue du tarif en tout cas sur le
fonctionnement de la décision si c'est
ça votre question en fait pour les
tarifs ou est-ce que c'est un sujet qui
dans tous les cas est monitory au niveau
ministériel et qui et qui vous est
soumis même si il y a pas de problème
quoi
le sujet t'arrive
le sujet à Rennes il fait partie des
sujets
[Musique]
qui moi me
confirme si vous voulez
si on cherche à voir comment les choses
risquent d'évoluer plus tard
qu'il faut qu'il faut sortir EDF du
statut de société anonyme l'hypothèse en
fait de la situation dans laquelle on
est sur le sur le sur l'arène elle est
déjà évoquée par un certain nombre
d'acteurs dans les débats de l'époque
alors je ne serai pas capable ma mémoire
n'étant pas celle d'un ordinateur de
vous dire qui quand comment et où mais
l'hypothèse d'une flambée des prix de
l'électricité
en Europe et c'est d'ailleurs je pense à
cause de ça qu'au moment de la réforme
des tarifs du gaz je fais mettre la
clause de sauvegarde qui a permis
d'ailleurs ensuite au premier en Castex
de bloquer les tarifs du gaz dans le
mécanisme des tarifaires sur le sur le
gaz c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné
l'état puisse
activer des solutions juridiques pour
reprendre le reprendre le contrôle
mais pour moi ça fait partie des sujets
qui motivent le fait de vouloir
organiser une reprise en main par la
nation de tout ça je veux le dire
d'ailleurs que la
le
la demande d'études de renationalisation
d'EDF à l'époque et immédiatement écarté
ce que je regrette mais elle a au moins
eu le mérite de bloquer le projet ou les
intentions de l'APE de diminuer la part
de l'État dans le capital d'EDF afin
d'améliorer sa valorisation boursière
merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames les ministres pour ces ondes
c'est très nombreux éléments et la
grande clarté de de vos réponses je vais
commencer par revenir sur la question
des 50% parce que je crois que
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs comme vous
avez pu le constater en écoutant nos
précédentes auditions et comme vous avez
pu le constater avec les questions du
Président nous sommes très loin de
remettre en cause la souveraineté
nationale et la représentation nationale
nous cherchons simplement à comprendre
les causes qui ont présidé aux décisions
politiques et je crois d'ailleurs que
c'est la mission de notre assemblée sur
les 50% si j'ai bien suivi votre
raisonnement et d'ailleurs effectivement
dans vos déclarations de l'époque vous
insistez d'abord prioritairement et
d'ailleurs vous êtes une voix assez
singulière sur la sortie du fossile et
donc vous à la fois dans vos
déclarations d'époque et comme vous
l'avez fait aujourd'hui vous vous
n'opposez pas les modes de production
d'électricité vous avez un discours
spécifique sur le nucléaire mais l'idée
est bien d'arriver de la priorité comme
vous l'avez mentionné au début de votre
propos liminaire
de prendre en compte l'urgence
climatique avec un horizon qui vous
semble plus proche que 2050 et qui est
2030 et donc de prioriser les combats
j'allais dire et donc de se concentrer
sur ce qui permettait de décarboner
notre production énergétique et vous
l'avez mentionné avec le fond chaleur
avec le développement de d'autres ENR
qui sont pas d'ailleurs nécessairement
électriques et ce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre c'est que des auditions
précédentes il ressort quand même qu'il
y avait bien une opposition entre les
énergies renouvelables électriques et le
nucléaire et ce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre c'est comment est-ce que ça
s'inscrit dans ce que vous ditesar qu'au
moment où vous arrivez aux
responsabilités il me semble que le
débat qui a été mis en place et encore
plus si on parle de baisse de
consommation et de maîtrise de la
demande c'est de dire finalement on ne
pense pas qu'on va augmenter on y
reviendra on ne pense pas qu'on va
augmenter notre consommation électrique
mais la priorité ça va être de baisser
la part du nucléaire dans le mix
électrique plutôt que de développer des
énergies renouvelables qui permettraient
de concurrencer les énergies fossiles et
c'est la question que vous avez mis sur
le transfert des usages donc ma question
c'est dans le débat de l'époque est-ce
que vous vous portez une voix un peu
différente qui consiste à dire attention
la priorité c'est bien de sortir du
défensiles tout ce temps qu'elle sont où
est-ce que finalement vous vous n'êtes
pas en phase avec l'idée que jusque là
il y a eu une forme d'opposition entre
ENR électrique et nucléaire si vous
voulez l'impression qu'on peut avoir
c'est que la priorité en en vous
écoutant et en écoutant nos principaux
nos précédents interlocuteurs c'est que
la priorité numéro 1 que vous décrivez
de la baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ne se serait pas
forcément traduite par une priorité
donnée à la décarbonation des usages et
donc des modes de production par énergie
fossile au profit d'une discussion qui a
son mais qui est peut-être moins
prioritaire de nucléaire versus
électricité production d'électricité à
partir d'énergie renouvelable
pardon monsieur un rapporteur mais
j'arrive pas tellement à suivre votre
votre raisonnement alors je reprends
dans l'exercice de mes fonctions je
n'exprime pas un point de vue personnel
j'exprime la position du gouvernement
mais dans les ce qui nous intéresse bien
comprendre le processus de décision donc
quand vous arrivez au gouvernement vous
êtes ministre vous vous décrivez
j'imagine ce que enfin en cohérence ce
que vous décrivez aujourd'hui la
priorité c'est la diminution des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
priorité absolue pour lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique c'est la baisse
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
la baisse de la facture énergétique et
la résorption de la précarité
énergétique et la diversification
énergétique mais donc comment est-ce que
la priorité alors peut-être que c'est
une histoire d'affichage politique et
que ça s'est traduit différemment dans
les faits et dans les décisions que vous
avez prises mais comment est-ce que le
débat peut-il autant se centrer sur
finalement deux modes de production vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
euh pardon la question pour la France du
de son retard dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables
n'est pas juste une question
comment dire de
d'affichage ou une question secondaire
et en fait je crois que c'est un élément
extrêmement central de discussion
actuelle on n'est pas dans les années 70
dans les années 70
on est on était quelque part dans un
choix
pétrole contre contre nucléaire
aujourd'hui il y a quelque chose de
nouveau qui a émergé qui s'appelle les
énergies renouvelables et qui est
globalement moins cher que le nouveau
nucléaire
pas que l'ancien c'est la raison pour
laquelle ma position est de distinguer
la question du parc nucléaire actuel on
pourrait y revenir si vous voulez de
celle du nouveau nucléaire donc non moi
ma feuille de ma feuille de route est
très et très claire à l'époque y compris
sur la question de la diversification
sur le plan de l'électricité la remarque
que je faisais c'est que dans le débat
sur les renouvelables on soulève les
questions d'intermittence des énergies
renouvelables électriques qui sont qui
est un sujet réel et donc on oublie que
la politique du renouvelable c'est pas
que des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires et que même si on parle du
solaire et bien il faut arrêter
d'oublier le solaire thermique qui
pourrait de façon extrêmement
utile remplacer la consommation
d'électrons d'électricité pour faire de
l'eau chaude
c'est ça la remarque que je faisais tout
à l'heure
donc je sais pas si on se comprend
la question qui en inspire d'autres
juste alors sur le dernier point d'abord
et puis je remettrai le fil du
raisonnement sur le développement des
énergies renouvelables c'est à partir
évidemment des considérations
économiques et industrielles mais c'est
à partir de 2007-2008 qu'on commence à
décrocher de nos objectifs voilà vous
restez un an responsabilité tant que
c'est forcément difficile mais en
revanche vous avez un à la fois un rôle
d'audition et puis de témoins de à la
fois de l'État quand vous arrivez et
puis ce que ce que vous laissez en
partant et donc ça m'inspire la bloc de
question d'abord à quoi on a récemment
voté enfin discuté et voter et vous y
avez contribué à une loi sur les
accélération des énergies renouvelables
comme il y a quelques années on en avait
déjà voté une et donc ma question pour
cette commission c'est bien sûr que vous
nous recitiez ce qui à l'époque vous
semble être les obstacles autant
d'installations que de production des
énergies renouvelables et la deuxième
chose qui rebondit sur ma question et
sur votre réponse c'est comment dans les
décisions que vous avez prises et dans
l'appareil d'État et des politiques
publiques qui sont mises en œuvre se
font les arbitrage s'il y en a ou en
tout cas la répartition de l'effort
entre les énergies renouvelables non
électriques qui ont vocation elles
directement à décarboner notre mix
énergétique et puis les énergies
renouvelables électriques qui certes
sont une nouvelle source
d'approvisionnement mais qui en terme de
démission de gaz à effet de serre
n'apporte pas grand chose par rapport à
notre mix électrique dans l'état de des
années 2010
ok alors d'abord sur votre question sur
à partir de 2007-2008 la France décroche
et d'ailleurs le décrochage s'est
poursuivi etc bon
il faut quand même dire
que le conservatisme énergétique que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure du couple
pétrole nucléaire
c'est un conservatisme qui aussi ne
croit pas au renouvelables
qui
croient pas que ça va marcher et qui
croit pas que ça va émerger
vraiment de façon profonde et en fait
cette vision là elle existe aussi dans
l'appareil d'État à l'époque
c'est-à-dire que c'est
[Musique]
vous voyez le la mise en avant permanent
de tel ou tel objection technique
industrielle etc
et donc des mécanismes de soutien en
fait qui sont mises en place
[Musique]
sous la pression de la tente citoyenne
de l'attente de la société civile en
fait que se développe les énergies
renouvelables en France mais sans
stratégie industrielle
et sans stratégie industrielle pardon
mais ça pose un problème parce que on
n'a pas la maîtrise des technologies
donc on retombe dans la case dépendant
de l'extérieur et parce que là où la
production énergétique passée par un
service public et un monopole avec le
modèle social lié à ce monopole y
compris pour les emplois induits par ce
monopole on n'a pas l'équivalent en fait
du côté des énergies renouvelables alors
qu'on a pu on aurait pu la voir ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'était pas une
fatalité mais ça nécessitait à mes yeux
de changer les règles du jeu c'est à
dire que la mécanique tarif de rachat
appelle d'offres secteur ouvert à la
concurrence c'est pas une mécanique qui
est propice au développement devrait
acteurs industriels
français ou européen
de de parce que la notion de
souveraineté que que j'ai beaucoup
développée je la vois à l'échelle
nationale mais pas recroqueviller sur
elle-même et pas en dehors de l'espace
européen bon donc voilà vraiment
il n'y croit pas
les les entreprises de de ils commencent
un peu je pense à
appréhender les choses mais c'est avant
que j'arrive aux responsabilités à mon
avis la question de l'éolien offshore
commence à
faire changer le regard
mais voilà pas pas avec un engagement
si vous voulez j'ai pas vu
les dirigeants que je voyais souvent des
grandes entreprises de l'énergie faire
le siège de mon bureau pour obtenir tel
ou tel décision
en faveur
de tel ou tel mécanisme de soutien aux
énergies renouvelables c'est plutôt les
petits acteurs subsistants des filières
qui venaient de subir 14 000 emplois en
moins qu'ils le fusaient
donc ça c'est la première question la
deuxième la deuxième de votre question
elle amène en fait à au sujet des
scénarios
donc il y a eu une production
très conséquente du débat national sur
la transition énergétique sur les sur
les scénarios qu'a repris tous les
scénarios existants précédemment
et qui a
fait un exercice d'ailleurs assez
comparable à ce qu'on voit avec les
scénarios de RTE dans la dans la période
la plus récente dont moi j'ai retenu une
chose
c'est que les débats sur ce que sera le
mixte énergétique en 2050 son
passionnants
stimulant intellectuellement nous invite
à avoir une vision de long terme mais la
conclusion des scénarios quand on les
regarde c'est que ils ont tous le même
point de départ
c'est à dire que si on prend une
métaphore sportive
il y a
les visions divergentes de notamment sur
le sur le la part d'électricité les
renouvelables nucléaires etc à l'horizon
il y a pas de scénario compatible avec
le facteur 4 quel que soit ensuite les
moyens de production utilisés qui ne
commence par diviser par deux
la consommation d'énergie et donc en
fait le point de départ la période de
départ en fait d'engagement d'une
transformation de l'ensemble des
scénarios est à peu près le même
et donc on peut avoir une vision mais
mon sentiment si vous voulez 10 ans
après
parce qu'on est 10 ans après
c'est que la façon dont le débat public
sur l'énergie
cultive
l'expertise la contre-expertise etc
c'est très bien sur un horizon de temps
lointain alors que ce qui compte c'est
ce qu'on fait entre maintenant et 2030
et que quoi qu'on décide pour 2050 la
priorité numéro 1 et d'investir dans les
économies d'énergie
me conduite à penser que la vraie
question aujourd'hui n'est pas tellement
celle du choix de scénario de référence
la vraie question aujourd'hui c'est
celle des leviers
donc de la nationalisation d'EDF des
marges d'action à l'échelle européenne
et de l'orientation claire sur le fait
que on va pas faire ce qui a été fait
dans le passé
alors que la question c'est à dire
investir dans des moyens de production
sans se poser de questions sur la
demande on va mettre le paquet sur la
réduction de la consommation d'énergie
et sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique parce que ce qui me frappe
aussi
y compris dans
les propos de beaucoup d'acteurs
sur le futur de la politique énergétique
c'est que bien des raisonnements
sont construits à climat constant
c'est un point extrêmement important
beaucoup de raisonnement sont construits
à climat constant ce qui fait que par
exemple
dans ce qu'écrit un des scénarios de RTE
sur
le nouveau nucléaire ce qui est pris en
considération c'est le nouveau le niveau
des cours d'eau
en 2050 alors que si vous si vous créez
si vous ouvrez un réacteur nucléaire en
il sera normalement encore en
fonctionnement en 2085 et que donc il
faut quand même se poser la question de
ce que seront
les conditions
de vie
et des écosystèmes et de la ressource en
eau etc à cette horizontale de temps là
ce que je suis en train de dire là ça
vaut pour l'ensemble en fait de
l'organisation du système énergétique et
si on croit s'agissant des énergies
renouvelables en fait qu'on peut les
développer en restant dans un modèle
sur le plan de l'électricité je parle là
qui est le même modèle que le nucléaire
en fait c'est à dire
avec le réseau national etc à mon avis
c'est pas la bonne logique sur le
renouvelable
du diffus sur le renouvelable de
l'autoconsommation
y compris de l'autoconsommation
collective à l'échelle locale etc et
complètement sous-estimé en fait et
c'est là qu'on voit que du coup il y a
un changement de modèle c'est à dire
qu'on doit garder
la péréquation tarifaire l'égalité des
tarifs évidemment une sécurité garantie
à chacun par le par le réseau donc les
choses doivent être interconnectées je
suis pas en train de plaider pour le
chacun pour soi énergétique mais par
contre dans la si vous voulez la
conception y compris en termes de
charges d'investissement
c'est sinon
à mon avis enfin c'est pas le bon modèle
et surtout c'est pas résilient c'est pas
résilient dans un contexte
d'accélération du réchauffement
climatique d'événements extrêmes de
catastrophes dont il est certain compte
tenu de ce qu'est l'inertie du système
climatique que même si nous arrivions à
limiter le réchauffement à 2 degrés à
l'échelle mondiale
les conséquences seraient déjà
extrêmement graves et certaines pour la
France
je vous remercie puisque vous avez parlé
de long terme je fais un détour par la
recherche et donc plutôt en matière
nucléaire parce que pour les recherches
de moyens long terme c'est plutôt le cas
lorsque vous arrivez au responsabilités
en 2010 le projet Astrid a été validé
lancé et depuis juillet 2010 le réacteur
expérimental iTER est en cours de
construction et le décret qui autorise
officiellement sa création est signée je
crois par vous ou en tout cas
par la par le Premier ministre quel est
votre vision à l'époque de la recherche
de moyens et de long terme en matière
nucléaire en particulier je prends
exemple ce qui sont par an sur la fusion
et sur la fission mes quatrième
génération puisque en termes de cycles
et environnementaux ils sont largement
différents est-ce que vous vous dites il
faut finalement comme on a pu le voir
certains interlocuteurs opposés à l'idée
qu'on puisse rester durablement pro
d'énergie électrique à partir du
nucléaire ce que vous êtes opposé et
vous vous opposez à cette recherche ou
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a une
vertu à imaginer une fermeture du cycle
voir la fusion nucléaire a beaucoup plus
long terme
bon alors la question est pas tellement
ce que je pense même si on pourra y
revenir
que oui oui j'ai bien compris que ce qui
a été fait est décidé
donc l'engagement qui avait été pris
était celui du maintien du projet du
programme Astrid
maintien qui a été acté par le Conseil
de politique nucléaire du 28 septembre
et en revanche la problématique qui
s'est posée assez vite dans le budget
alors je sais plus si c'est pour 2013 ou
2014 du CEA et celui d'une part de
l'austérité budgétaire d'autre part
d'une volonté politique
assumée
de ne pas faire supporter l'ensemble des
coupes budgétaires sur les budgets de
recherche aux énergies renouvelables
puisque en fait dans dans si vous voulez
le
ce qui était le grand emprunt qui est
devenu les investissements d'avenir et
tout ce qui était étudié par le Conseil
Général à l'Investissement
il y avait une mécanique
budgétaire qui se posait sur les les
efforts demandés aux uns par rapport aux
efforts demandés aux autres pas en
termes de parties prenantes mais le
choix pour la nation sur quoi on
investit en termes de recherche et donc
moi j'étais clairement opposé à ce qu'on
diminue les budgets de l'ADEME à ce
qu'on diminue l'effort de recherche sur
les énergies renouvelables avec y
compris les enjeux de filière
industrielles qu'on vient d'évoquer tout
en maintenant au même niveau les crédits
pour le projet Astrid des donc mon
souvenir c'est qu'avec Geneviève fiorazo
qui était la ministre de la de la
recherche on a étalé on a diminué
budgétairement le et on a demandé au CEA
d'étaler son plan de travail on en était
même pas à l'avant-projet sommaire ou
alors on en était juste à l'avant-projet
sommaire sur Astrid la deuxième chose
c'est que ma priorité
concernant le CEA était qu'il
réponde aux mises en demeure de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire sur la
sécurité de
vieilles installations
et donc là aussi j'ai pu soutenir de
tous les détails mais il y avait une
mécanique budget du CEA dans son
ensemble entre le programme Astrid et
des obligations de sûreté et pour la
ministre que j'étais la sûreté n'était
pas négociable du tel entraîné des
retards sur le programme sur le
programme Astrid après ma conviction
puisque vous demandez ma conviction
personnelle moi je suis favorable à la
recherche sur tout
donc je ne suis pas pour arrêter
la recherche
sur le nucléaire par contre la question
que la nation doit se poser
c'est peut-être un peu d'ouvrir ses
horizons
de vision c'est à dire que cette idée
que la quatrième génération
va nous sauver des limites planétaires
avec une solution magique va être trouvé
pour avoir une espèce de nucléaire
perpétuel
est une vision des choses telles qu'on
pouvait la penser
avant que nemerge les enjeux de
recherche sur le stockage
de l'énergie
et donc si on me demandait aujourd'hui
sur quoi faut mettre le paquet en terme
de en termes de vision d'avenir il y a
un autre modèle en fait de des
changements de la problématique
notamment par rapport à ce qu'on
évoquait en lien avec les énergies
renouvelables qui est l'enjeu du
stockage mais je n'ai pas une position
de principe de vouloir interdire la
recherche fondamentale même la recherche
expérimentale sur la question de
l'énergie nucléaire
indépendamment de ce que je pense de
l'avenir du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique
une question adjacente simplement parce
que je l'ai déjà posé à vos
prédécesseurs
est-ce que dans la au cours de
l'exercice de vos fonctions puisque vous
parliez de sûreté et vous avez
d'ailleurs eu des déclarations pour
enfin vous avez expliqué et puis il est
avéré que vous êtes battus pour garder
le niveau des crédits en matière de
sûreté nucléaire est-ce que dans le
cours de vos fonctions vous avez pu vous
avez eu l'impression ou plus constater
qu'il y avait un arbitrage entre sûreté
et production et que d'une quelconque
manière la sûreté des installations
nucléaires n'étaient pas garantie au
meilleur niveau possible en l'état des
connaissances et avec l'appui de la SN
et de l'IRSN
c'est toujours un risque
et c'est la conscience de ce risque qui
m'a amené à proposer la nomination de
Pierre Franck chevet
dont j'avais pu
mesurer les capacités d'indépendance
et à dire les choses telles qu'il les
pensaient
au gouvernement mais aussi à résister à
la pression des opérateurs
on choisit un président de l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire sur cette base là à mes
yeux
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
c'est que
écoutez ça rouspétait sur
déterminant fixés par la SN sur le poste
kushima mais avec
un engagement très clair d'EDF et
d'arriver à le respecter et a donc être
au niveau
attendu du poste Fukushima
votre question
m'amène
à émettre une alerte
sur ce dont j'ai pris connaissance hier
concernant
l'idée
que porte le gouvernement de vouloir
réformer la sûreté nucléaire en France
en fusionnant
l'ASN et l'IRSN
ça me paraît absolument contraire à
l'intérêt national en matière de sûreté
nucléaire
le nucléaire reste une énergie
extrêmement dangereuse
dangereuse parce que la question
j'entends parfois dans les débats
n'est pas
seulement celle du nombre de victimes
alors avec les raisonnements absurdes où
on compare le nombre de victimes qui
pourraient y avoir d'un accident
nucléaire au nombre de victimes des
accidents de la route ou je ne sais quoi
la question c'est la durée des
conséquences d'un accident nucléaire
qui se compte en milliers d'années
donc c'est pas un risque
qu'on peut se permettre de sous-évaluer
et surtout le principe de base de la
sûreté nucléaire c'est l'humilité
c'est pas de se dire qu'on est les plus
forts et qu'on maîtrise tout c'est de se
dire qu'un accident est possible en
France
c'est le principe central de la Sûreté
Nucléaire et donc cette idée de
fusionner la SN et l'IRSN est une très
mauvaise idée parce que de la même façon
que pour faire la loi c'est très bien
d'avoir le BIC à mérisme et bien c'est
très bien en matière de sûreté nucléaire
d'avoir une expertise
scientifique radiologique etc à l'IRSN
et d'avoir une autorité de sûreté
nucléaire
et que le cas échéant si ça s'avère
nécessaire moi je n'en ai pas fait
l'expérience
il y est la certitude que si une
pression s'exercait pour en raison de
des urgences de la production ou je ne
sais quoi obtenir de la SN ceci ou cela
et bien il y a au travers d'un organisme
qui n'est pas assujetti
fonctionnellement à elle la possibilité
que de
des alertes remontent
je vous remercie
vous venez de terminer sur la question
que j'allais vous poser suite aux
annonces du dernier Conseil national sur
le nucléaire
vous veuillez m'excuser pour mon retard
mais j'ai suivi par ailleurs l'audition
au démarrage j'avais quelques questions
vous êtes revenu sur le débat national
de la transition énergétique
j'aimerais plus précisément peut-être
avoir votre retour sur l'expérience
de ce débat
les organisations industrielles et
patronales ont été assez critiques sur
le déroulé vous avez tout à l'heure
évoqué le conservatisme des industriels
ou en tout cas de l'industrie en
particulier nucléaire est-ce qu'ils ont
tenté de freiner des cas de fers sur la
réduction
et puis les moyens pour attendre
atteindre les 50% en 2025 est-ce qu'ils
ont été concertés dans le cadre ce débat
là vous avez été très ferme sur
l'interdiction d'exploitation sur les
gaz de schiste est-ce que dans le cadre
de ce débat les industriels favorables à
l'exploitation des gaz de schisme ont
fait pression il me semble qu'il y avait
un désaccord là aussi avec le ministre
Arnaud Montebourg
pour vous est-ce que l'une des grandes
questions du débat était que l'État
puisse reprendre la main sur les
décisions de la politique énergétique et
est-ce que à l'époque vous considérez
que la politique n'avait pas la main sur
les enjeux énergétiques et en
particulier sur la filière du nucléaire
avec les conséquences aussi sur les
autres filières et notamment sur le les
renouvelables
qu'en est-il aujourd'hui et qu'elle a
été la votre réaction enfin la réaction
de l'ensemble des parties prenantes à
l'annonce
[Musique]
le renvoi quelques jours à peine avant
la fin des débats est-ce qu'on peut dire
que le dnte ne présentait pas vraiment
d'enjeux pour le président concernant
les choix énergétiques de la France
c'est un
en fait
je pense qu'on peut
comparer
ce qui s'est passé avec le débat
national sur la transition énergétique
avec ce qui s'est passé avec la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
c'est à dire que les présidents veulent
[Musique]
qui a un processus
de concertation des laboration de
discussions citoyenne que ce processus
puisse marquer l'histoire d'une
évolution de la politique française
et puis une fois que le processus est
mis en place
en fait nécessairement il échappe à leur
déshydrateur il échappe au désiderata
des présidents des conseillers des chefs
d'entreprise parce qu'une fois que la
discussion citoyenne se noue sur ce
qu'il faut pour le pour l'intérêt du
pays et ben c'est pas une vision qu'on
conservatrice qui en sort et donc
l'expertise scientifique
la discussion avec les parties prenantes
pas seulement les ONG mais aussi les
organisations syndicales je ne sais pas
moi les représentants du monde agricole
les organisations patronales en fait
quand on va au bout de la discussion
sérieuse
tout le monde veut du changement en fait
le secteurs économiques ils ont besoin
d'une prévisibilité de l'avenir de la
politique énergétique quel est le
problème par exemple aujourd'hui des
entreprises de la plus de la plus petite
à l'établissement de taille
intermédiaire c'est pas seulement c'est
pour ça que il y a un truc qui va pas
c'est que c'est pas seulement d'avoir
une aide pour payer la facture c'est de
savoir dans leur plan de charge par
rapport à leur production et par rapport
à ce que
l'énergie il consomme pour fabriquer tel
et telle chose à quel prix sera le tarif
dans combien de temps en fait
donc oui il y a une il y a une
confrontation c'est ce que j'ai évoqué
dans mon propos liminaire il y a une
confrontation entre
tout processus de nature démocratique
qu'elle soit
et le conservatisme
énergétique effectivement dans le cas du
débat national
et pas que il y a eu
un militantisme important de très très
nombreux acteurs
pour que la France revienne sur
l'interdiction de la fracturation
hydraulique concernant le gaz de schiste
ça fait partie de ce que j'évoquais dans
mon propos liminaire sur le fait que
c'était souvent les mêmes acteurs que
ceux qui
refusaient la fermeture de la centrale
de Fessenheim ou la diminution de la
part du nucléaire dans le mix électrique
je ne sais pas si j'ai répondu oui oui
toutes ces questions justement sur la
fermeture de Fessenheim et sur
l'objectif fixé dans la loi très
critiquée aujourd'hui
sur de transitions énergétique pour la
croissance verte et 50 % en 2025
deux questions en fait le premier
puisqu'on les a posé un peu à tous les
auditionner est-ce que à votre sens
cette horizon qui avait été fixé dans la
loi
est-ce que tout a été fait à tous les
étages de l'État pour pouvoir le
réaliser le concrétiser ou est-ce qu'on
a choisi de afficher un objectif
politique qui paraissait et est-ce qu'il
paraissait techniquement faisable ou
tenable avec les experts qu'il y avait
et qui avait aussi contribué à j'imagine
fixer ce seuil ça c'est
une des questions et puis l'engagement
pris devant les Français de fermeture de
Fessenheim est-ce qu'il a été remise en
question autour de cette loi Ségolène
Royal que nous avons auditionné hier
affirmé que la fermeture de Fessenheim
avait été conditionnée à l'ouverture de
flamants ville
est-ce que c'est pour cela qu'elle a
tardé à acter sa fermeture et à ce
qu'elle dit vrai selon vous ok alors
d'abord sur le les 50% comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure
c'était faisable
2028-2030 à partir du moment ce qui
était ma position
où on exclut de mettre en place des
cycles combinés gaz ou je ne sais quoi
pour se substituer à une diminution du
nucléaire est-ce que
donc le scénario 2025 c'est-à-dire
l'année 2025 elle-même impliquait une
augmentation de
du bilan carbone de la production
d'électricité qui de mon point de vue
était automatiquement exclu est-ce que
ensuite les moyens
d'atteindre même l'horizon de 2028 ont
été déployés non absolument pas parce
qu'en fait les 50% comme la question de
la fermeture de Fessenheim
amène à la question centrale
de l'avenir du parc nucléaire existant
et pour moi la diminution de la part du
nucléaire c'est une question de
résilience et de diminution de la
vulnérabilité c'est-à-dire que je pense
que dans le monde actuel et dans le
monde qui vient dépendre d'une diversité
de source d'approvisionnement électrique
est une plus grande sécurité que de tout
dépend d'une seule d'une seule
technologie mais c'est aussi une
problématique industrielle et économique
c'est à dire qu'en fait l'âge du parc
fait qu'il y a ce qu'on appelle la
falaise ou un mur d'investissement et
que donc il y a une rationalité
économique et industrielle pour diminuer
la charge qui pèse sur la nation et sur
l'opérateur à vouloir casser ce mur et
donc à fermer des réacteurs même s'ils
auraient pu être prolongés et en
prolonger d'autres
et donc la première question
que j'ai posé à la direction de
l'énergie et du climat lors de ma
première rencontre avec avec eux lorsque
j'ai été nommée ministre
c'est pourriez-vous me transmettre
l'étude
des services sur les différents
scénarios
de prolongations du parc nucléaire
et les coûts les procédures
les différentes hypothèses
et ma surprise a été que cette étude
n'existait pas
il y avait
[Musique]
rapidement une note
m'expliquant ce qui avait été fait
jusqu'ici il y avait eu une demande de
la ministre qui a été en charge de la
Sûreté Nucléaire auprès de la SN pour
savoir comment la SN allait déterminer
sa position sur sur cette question mais
c'est tout ce qu'il y avait
et c'était un élément pour moi qui
devait être dans cette question du
faisable en 2028 etc et donc dans les
conclusions du débat national puis
ensuite dans la programmation de la loi
et des moyens budgétaires avec
de savoir
le nombre de réacteurs à fermer d'ici
à mon avis un choix de fermeture qui
devait relever de l'opérateur et de RTE
en raison des questions de
fonctionnement du système électrique
à l'échelle nationale et des choix de de
prolongation
donc en fait l'essentiel de ce qu'on m'a
dit à ce moment-là sur la question de de
prolongation c'est que la vie générique
de l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire était
attendue en 2015
je crois que c'est celui qui est
intervenu en fait beaucoup
beaucoup plus tard
j'ai néanmoins
[Musique]
engagé le fait de faire passer
l'amortissement comptable des centrales
à 50 ans dans les dans les comptes de DF
qui a été matérialisé beaucoup plus tard
je n'ai jamais compris pourquoi je ne
sais pas si vous éclairerez
ce point et moi je reste convaincu
aujourd'hui
qu'il faut fermer des réacteurs
et que l'état de fête dans lequel nous
sommes
conduit très certainement à la nécessité
d'en prolonger d'autres à cause du
retard qui a été pris je dis très
certainement
parce que
je ne sais pas si c'est possible
et qu'en fait dans les sujets dont nous
sommes en train de discuter donc moi
c'est ma position je serai pour qu'on
diminue qu'on enferme et ça oblige
d'après moi à en prolonger d'autres
parce qu'on n'a pas de moyens de
remplacement
immédiat et qu'on doit avoir une vision
résiliente de l'avenir du pays
je ne sais pas si c'est possible je vois
les débats qui entourent la possibilité
de prolonger à 60 ou 80 ans en fait
aujourd'hui on a très peu de choses pour
savoir si c'est possible il n'y a pas de
il y a pas d'avis de l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire et l'histoire m'a
appris
qu'il faut être extrêmement prudent
avec toute forme d'affirmation
dans ce dans ce domaine c'est à dire
qu'en fait
le constat c'est que la filière
nucléaire
aujourd'hui
elle a un problème majeur de fiabilité
de ce qu'elle dit
de ce qu'elle assure comme étant
certains possibles etc quand sur un
chantier vous dites c'est sûr ça va
ouvrir en 2012 puis ensuite c'est sûr ça
va ouvrir en 2016
c'est moi j'ai cru quand j'ai dit
au nom de la France et devant le peuple
français que le père allait ouvrir en
je l'ai dit en pensant que les
informations qu'on me donnait étaient
bien évidemment vrai
et c'est un problème
c'est un problème majeur en fait c'est
un fiasco et en fait j'ai eu je le dis
j'ai eu dans des situations des choses
complètement différentes avec la
question du nucléaire sur de la des
éléments de gestion de crise
ce réflexe
de refuser alors que la question était
posée mais quand est-ce que le problème
soit soit résolu etc et des services qui
vous diront qui vous disent vous pouvez
annoncer que ça va être résolu à telle
date j'ai eu le réflexe de dire non en
fait on sait pas on n'en sait rien et
donc de dire la vérité et si j'étais
aujourd'hui en situation de
responsabilité et qu'on me disait madame
quand est-ce que le Pr va produire de
l'électricité je dirais je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas parce que on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas jouer avec la crédibilité
de la parole publique c'est pas possible
et même du point de vue industriel c'est
le problème majeur aujourd'hui de la
filière nucléaire
cette problématique de fiabilité
la fiabilité la règle de base de
l'industrie mais c'est aussi la règle de
base de la politique
je crois que j'ai oublié la question sur
Fessenheim donc Fessenheim en fait
fermer un réacteur
[Musique]
l'expression à l'époque ne se fait pas
comme on éteint la lumière
d'abord il y a des emplois ensuite il y
a des enjeux de sûreté nucléaire
il y a un territoire
et donc ça doit être préparé et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'en fait si vous
voulez plus on est dans le statu quo moi
on décide de rien moi on prépare moins
au final ça va devenir ingérable
complètement ingérable
parce que
même si certains sont pour un nouveau
parc nucléaire ce qui n'est pas mon cas
va falloir fermer des réacteurs et ça se
prépare de fermer des réacteurs
donc le temps que
que ça a pris il renvoie à sa dimension
là et après il renvoie au fait que des f
est une société anonyme
et donc une société anonyme
elle a un intérêt social
l'État ne fait pas ce qu'il veut
et d'ailleurs je suis assez d'accord
même si des indemnisations peuvent être
constitutionnellement exigé c'est pour
ça c'est un des éléments pour lesquels
je suis pour la nationalisation je suis
assez d'accord avec les remarques de la
Cour des comptes
sur les conditions d'indemnisation d'EDF
concernant Fessenheim n'a jamais été
démontré que Fessenheim pouvait produire
de l'électricité jusqu'en 2041 et donc
je vois pas pourquoi il faut indemniser
sur une hypothèse de production jusqu'en
2041 ça me paraît pas raisonnable
vous avez répondu sur les 50% sur le
volet nucléaire mais pas forcément
puisque pour arriver à un mix
énergétique de 50%, c'est aussi la
montée en puissance des énergies
renouvelables c'était la deuxième partie
quelque part de la question vous avez
expliqué et expliciter ça je sais pas si
vous voulez juste répondre sur les
énergies renouvelables aussi
en fait on y a consacré à temps
important
sur ce que sur monsieur Proglio puisque
il nous a si on revient sur flamment
ville par exemple lui il nous a dit
effectivement et ça résonne avec les
propos que vous venez tenir sur la
fiabilité d'une filière il nous a
expliqué que au doigt mouillé il lui
avait dit donner une date et qu'il avait
pris deux ans de sécurité c'est à peu
près ça qui nous a dit l'heure de son
audition pour dire bah deux ans de
retard voilà donc je vais annoncer ça
donc ça ça résonne avec la fiabilité et
du coup la parole publique qui est
engagée si la filière en fait ne sait
pas elle-même et masque quelque part
la réalité ou la vérité et qui fait que
ça nous entraîne et en termes de de
robustesse de la filière mais également
ça engage la parole publique à avoir des
décalages et affirmer des choses qui
infinie ne sont pas vraies sur vos
relations avec Monsieur Proglio
il a été maintenu il était proche de
Sarkozy il a été maintenu à la tête de
EDF par le Président de la République
François Hollande
malgré notamment sa fermeture ferme
enfin son opposition pardon ferme à la
fermeture de Fessenheim est-ce que vous
avez compris le choix du président de la
République à l'époque et est-ce que vous
avez été associé à cette décision après
votre départ du gouvernement vous avez
déclaré que l'influence du PDG de d'EDF
auprès de l'Élysée
concurrençay celle du ministère de du
ministre de l'écologie comment se sont
passés quand vous étiez ministre vos
relations avec la direction d'EDF
l'énergéticien contre les par l'État 85%
à l'époque portait-il exécutait-il les
orientations politiques du gouvernement
en matière de transition énergétique
est-ce qu'il était pleinement engagé et
vous venez de
d'expliciter toutes les conditions pour
réussir la fermeture une centrale est
compréhenderme de d'impact sociaux et
économique est-ce que il a contribué ou
est-ce qu'il a du coup traîné des pieds
et puis ministre encore vous étiez
fermement opposé à une ouverture plus
forte au secteur privé vous venez dans
de le rappeler du capital d'EDF quel
était à l'époque la positionnement du
PDG d'EDF c'est à dire de Monsieur
Proglio
alors
il y avait plusieurs éléments avant d'en
venir à la question sur sur le PDG d'EDF
sur le Pr je voulais juste faire
remarquer que
une partie de mon expérience
en tout cas ce que j'ai vu entendu et ce
que j'ai fini par penser moi-même
c'est que
c'est trop gros
et en fait une
un très grand nombre d'acteurs de la
filière nucléaire ne sont pas convaincus
par ce modèle de réacteur c'est
la réalité c'est notamment en tout cas
dans les échanges que nous avions le
point de vue du PDG de DF
je sais pas si c'est ce qui vous a dit
aussi ou pas
ensuite
sur
Henri Proglio nous avions des relations
franche
et clairement pas j'allais dire mais en
toute en toute franchise clairement pas
la même la même vision en fait
de l'avenir de la politique énergétique
ça veut pas dire qu'on n'était pas
capable de se comprendre sur un certain
nombre de sujets notamment sur la
problématique de la trajectoire
tarifaire d'EDF
mais je me suis pas cachée de vouloir
sont remplacement que je n'ai pas obtenu
mais j'en suis vite arrivé à la
conclusion
que croire que c'était juste un sujet de
qui est le PDG de DF est une erreur
et c'est ce qui m'a amené
au sujet de la nationalisation il y a un
autre élément déterminant sur la
question de la nationalisation qui est
celle de l'hydroélectricité
qui est extrêmement importante
pardon mais il serait question de
privatiser 20% du parc nucléaire
français je pense qu'on en parlera tous
les jours
c'est 68% de la capacité de pointe
hydroélectricité c'est un bijou c'est un
patrimoine national
et donc il faut
je vois le rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui est sorti hier c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment extrêmement
important que ça reste dans le giron
dans le giron public donc non je n'ai
pas demandé à Henri pourrios son avis
sur
ce qui n'est jamais devenu
comment dire un projet puisque ma
demande auprès du président de la
République et du Premier ministre
c'était qu'il y ait une expertise
c'est-à-dire que soit mise à l'étude
la possibilité juridique budgétaire de
renationaliser EDF ce qui permettait de
reprendre la main et par ailleurs de
régler aussi juridiquement la question
de l'avenir des barrages hydrauliques
je pense
en tout cas j'ai fait le tour des
questions que j'avais parce que les
réponses aux précédentes questions
étaient également assez complètes sur
tous les autres sujets
je vous remercie juste une dernière
question enfin on repense que vous avez
dit parce que vous avez parlé du fait
que vous avez parlé des informations qui
est qui vous aider ou qui ont été
communiqués auprès des sœurs à vos
successeurs sur le chantier de l'EPR de
Flamanville en disant qu'elle n'était
pas vrai est-ce que est-ce que vous
voulez dire que les informations qui
vous ont été transmises en fait
finalement on était plus fiables parce
que le retard c'était accumulé ou est-ce
que vous considérez qu'on vous a
délibérément transmis des indications
fausses alors ça je ne peux pas
l'affirmer
ça veut pas dire que ce soit un sujet
clos
le problème c'est un problème de
fiabilité donc je suis pas du tout en
train de dire
qu'il y a une intention
de faire des rappels calendriers de
faire exploser le budget
en le multipliant par je ne sais plus
combien
c'est énorme
il y a quand même quand on regarde le
rapport de la Cour des comptes sur le
sujet il y a quand même des problèmes
qui n'ont pas été signalés à la SN dans
les délais requis etc enfin il y a quand
même
normalement si vous voulez un
fiasco de cette ampleur il doit être
analysé en long en large et en travers
et puis surtout on fait pas on refait
pas la même erreur c'est à dire
d'annoncer des nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires pour des raisons politiques
alors que le modèle de réacteur son
design n'est même pas n'est même pas
encore
terminé selon les ingénieurs c'est c'est
pas possible la conclusion a tiré de du
problème de de Flamanville c'est pas
juste le fait que c'était un réacteur
tout seul là où la filière avait appris
dans le passé à pouvoir régler les
problèmes en construisant plusieurs
réacteurs en même temps c'est pas vrai
donc non je ne vraiment je ne suis pas
en train de dire qu'il y a intention de
mensonges ce que je dis c'est que quand
on affirme
auprès des gouvernants comme dans le
débat public publiquement des
engagements sur un budget sur un
calendrier et qu'on est en permanence
obligé d'annoncer un dérapage de temps
et un dérapage de coût à la fin les gens
n'ont plus confiance
parce qu'ils savent pas si le nouveau
calendrier le nouveau coup c'est vrai
tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
l'expérience chez échaudé craint l'eau
froide ils ont ils ont l'expérience du
fait que la précédente fois où on leur a
dit c'était pas vrai
mais juste pour parce que en fait vous
n'êtes pas la seule ministre à
vous apporter une nuance c'est à dire
vous dites vous dites je ne sais pas si
c'était intentionnelle ou s'il n'avait
pas les éléments eux-mêmes vous dites je
ne peux pas juger de l'un ou de l'autre
et je ne crois pas en rien ne me permet
de dire que c'est cette intentionnel
pour autant pas sur Flamanville mais
dans sur le sujet du nucléaire en
général
Dominique voanet par exemple nous a
indiqué que lors d'une inondation de la
centrale nucléaire du Blayais le 31
décembre 1999 par hasard en allant
amener des chocolats au personnel qui
travaillent ce soir là en révision pour
veiller au black-out elle se rend compte
qu'il y a ça qui est en train de se
passer et elle n'est pas informée en
tant que ministre et donc responsable
notamment sur les questions de sûreté et
donc est-ce que vous vous avez des
exemples de ce type de situation vous en
tant que ministre vous n'avez pas les
éléments en tout cas vous avez
l'impression que les éléments ne vous
sont pas transmis en temps et en heure
oui avec deux précisions
d'abord sur le Blayais
que le problème le plus sérieux qu'on
est connu en France dans la période
récente
qui est très important
pour l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
il y a des conclusions qui ont été
tirées de cette de cet incident à la
fois en terme de risque
histoire des ambacks etc et aussi en
termes de Procédure
donc je dis ça parce que j'ai écouté cet
extrait de ce que disait Dominique
voannet et je me disais que elle ne
savait pas à quel point ça avait dans la
suite de l'histoire
eu des prolongements ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième
c'est que j'ai constaté de nombreux
dysfonctionnements de la gestion de
crise
au ministère de l'écologie qui n'était
pas propre au nucléaire
et qui n'ont jamais été
le même type de de fait c'est à dire un
incident de sûreté qui ne serait pas
remonté le ministère a maintenant des
procédures et le moindre incident de
sûreté il est immédiatement signalé au
cabinet et au ministre
par contre
un incident dans une centrale nucléaire
qui n'est pas un incident de sûreté
n'est pas signalé donc par exemple
par exemple
j'ai appris par une alerte de une alerte
vous savez comme
notification
de BFM TV ou de je ne sais qui avait un
incendie à la centrale nucléaire de
Fessenheim un incendie sans conséquence
en matière de sûreté voilà et donc nous
avons fait faire un rapport d'inspect
d'inspection en fait sur toutes les
mécaniques d'un certain nombre
d'événements que la culture des services
a tendance à appeler des événements
médiatiques parce que c'est pas des
événements qui engagent si vous voulez
le
la sûreté
mais qui sont quand même qui sont quand
même problématiques et puis j'ai eu
j'avais eu l'occasion de
développer devant une autre commission
d'enquête au Sénat ce qu'il en était de
la gestion de crise de façon générale en
matière de risque industriel mais j'ai
pas eu à constater la même chose que
Dominique Voynet en matière de sûreté
nucléaire c'est-à-dire de problèmes
engageant
des conséquences en termes de radio de
radioprotection
chaque incidente sûreté était remonté
je vous remercie parce que c'est la
première fois que ça arrive mais je
pense que le président n'avait pas
d'autres alternatives mais comme il est
parti c'est moi qui préside la séance je
me suis rapporté à ce que vous avez des
questions complémentaires dans ce cas là
je vous remercie pour la précision des
éléments que vous nous avez apporté